qualcuno si è dimenticato lo shop
testimoni di geova promesso salve entrò
in casa posso capirlo che natale è
passato ma non è che devi fare per forza
il cosplay di gesù cioè calmati 0
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fa vj ed oggi sono tornati sul
rendendo siamo quasi alla fine tra
l'altro mancano cinque livelli partiamo
quel primo che sono devo devo vedere se
riesco a finirlo veramente east episodio
sarebbe troppo figo in realtà i ragazzi
non ci spererei mai ex atto proprio
quello che stavo dicendo di finirlo in
ogni episodio
grazie non o qualcos'altro per cortesia
perfetto tanto sto tizio ragazzi si
tiene in discesa con una gamba sola
impossibile commettendo una vita solo
per arriva nel primo checkpoint ragazzi
tanta roba
tanta roba tanta roba tanta merda
ragazza posso fare ce l'ha fatta
lo faccia arrivare invece arrivo arrivo
arrivo
ok fantasma la lama no la lama e baffi
vabbè che cazzo è anche cazzo se non
giocando a baseball dal primo momento in
cui l'ho dal primo momento in cui ho
messo mano su sta roba qui mi è venuta
l'emicrania
non sto scherzando non posso rimanere
così svenuto sulla tavoletta qual è il
problema
c'è tanto non possono ammazzarmi
comunque credo è credo non ne so
sicurissimo
non mi possono mai peccare d'acqua come
come posso stare così non ho schiacciato
sono impiglia così via
questo mia figlia mi sono fatta giocava
pre praga tanta roba pollici in su a
manetta per lo svenimento che mi hai
servito tantissimo perfetto poi svenire
più spesso per favore ve lo chiedo è
grazie ragazzi sta diventanto un board è
però propri semplice degli altri pensavo
peggio
attenzione che fa vj ha parlato è ormai
lo sapevo io non c'è neanche bisogno di
dire di quanto sono incazzato lo vedi la
velista faccin incazzata che non c'ha i
brividi
potrei essere molto peggio nota c'e mia
quando finirò sto gioco accendo un cero
in chiesa come ci arrivo al check point
a ha già che posso fare è certo adesso
sì che posso abbassarmi posso stare così
tutto il livello qual è il problema
è questo il problema esaltare di quadro
saltari quando salta di qua eh vabbè non
solo prenderne un altro già che ci sei
aiuto bene bene ti sei salvato non lo
sapete voi ma questa quella mossa
tattica per salvarsi dalle lame ci si
stacca la testa ci si abbassa e si
cammina con la testa è la picchia
[Musica]
ma è la ma ad oggi in aste vite
parallele anzi zombie vite parallele ce
l'ho fatta siamo arrivati in un punto
che gli aveva preso tutto il resto
tranne le braccia mi ha attaccato le
braccia
dove vado di qua si faccia ragazzi c'è
una gamba non so se ve ne siete resi
conto
c'è una gamba only le gambe c'è solo
questa e non è che posso cazzo si cosa
ho fatto
cosa ho fatto con la gambetta e vabbè
dai non ci arriverò mai nella vita
marcel check point ragazzi ok ok ok si è
la madonna che partita ci ho provato ci
ho provato ci ho provato non so se sono
l'unico però io da piccolo guardavo un
sacchismo takeshi's castle che non so se
lo conosce qualcuno però è veramente
simile a parte e sangue va beh quella
madonna che culo che come lo so ho
sudato freddo mi carica siamo arrivati
ci posso credere
sei anni di livello fa chi è arrivati al
mare anche 44 fantastico dai ragazzi 4 1
alla fine ce la posso fare non sento
così patto fra il fatto e sega non sa
manco visto come livello non frega
niente effetto incassa rivolge poi così
senza neanche guardare fantastico
affetto grandissimo dorato cioè subito
che faccia una volta dato la stessa
facciata un banco quando la scuola non
so se tipo consolarla cosa bella bella
cioè primo check point ragazzi preso in
un nanosecondo gli altri probabilmente
no però vabbè ma dai ma mica che il
tempismo dai bradipo in calore maniaco o
complimenti cioè la forza di un
manichino sotto sedativi o è la madonna
bravissimo ok perfetto con una gamba e
ragazzi non vorrei dire con una gamba ma
anche altre ragazze cos'è sta roba a
domandarvi qua che figo i percorsi
piccoli sì mi ricordo un tipo crash
bandicoot
tua sorella putrefatta non toccare le
mie gambe sex in touch gesù ha aperto le
gambe mi servite potreste tornare che mi
servite no complimenti per il tempismo
che è sempre magnifico ratto ragazzi con
tutte ste la mesto gioco e sponsorizzato
sicuramente da gillet vero zio gillet il
meglio di uno zombie semi per il culo di
melo prima che mi preparo almeno quello
che sta roba
c'è la porta qualcuno si è dimenticato
look shop testimoni di geova promesso
salve entrò in casa così e non è che
faccio qualcuno c'ha un bottone da
schiacciare che devo schiavi
salve sono io che bello che ci avete
imposto 7 miei fan
ciao complimenti per le stanze
bellissime un'altra per favore perfetto
cazzo dire se più brutto da in carcere
in bocca lo chiamano piane vabbè piano
via non c'è più le braccia fantastico
ben e volendo potrei prenderti ma non
c'ho voglia quindi ragazzi in quarto
d'oro aveva st kucka taxi vostre gli
ultimi due li lascio per l'ultimo
episodio perché mi sa che è troppo lungo
acid pool party a c'è un pulsante ma ci
arrivo da quale nicchia
minchia va a 3 sporca la [ __ ] laida
non ci arrivavo per un millimetro l'ho
preso ma veramente non è fantastico sono
arrivato qua cosa faccio ace il check
point non dà il suo ok ok
l'ho preso allora non c è poi ciò
abbiamo ne mancano tre
praticamente ragazzi io svuotando
continuamente una piscina fatta di db
caccole sciolte vabbè ma chi ci arriva
mai
[Musica]
bravo bravo complimenti fai vai vai vai
zio quadratino troppa troppa roba se un
saltato praticamente tutto il livello
ragazzi fantastico che belli se faccio
immerse giovato ad ok giusto tutto al
gol
siamo arrivati a gol grandissimo mamma
mi che affaccia cast non ci credo al
piano piano giusto non ci credo si già
fatta volta ce l'ha fatta
mio dio quanta ansia 44 minuti equa e 40
anni
basterà che non ce la posso più fare
d'accordo ragazzi ad ora l'ultimo
episodio però gli ultimi due livelli e
poi ho finito il gioco in teoria parte
livelli bon vendere cassoli spero che
vide vi sia piaciuto concludo che
l'episodio di oggi
se avete bisogno di qualcuno gli
l'idraulico per la cina non per l'acqua
per la cina ci pensa zio farvi c'è
proprio io schiacci i tasti che che si
svuotano cosa sai che se ti e piaciuto
sull'argomento non mi piace anche a
fagiani facebook e con invito a trattare
sfiziose prestiti schifani ci vediamo la
prossima vitobello ragazzi